[Music]
morning guys I just pulled up I'm about
to go film some more hey [ __ ] and I
thought I would take you guys with me
today and look the hay bridge that moved
this is not the usual cause look
different size and we have to move sets
because the Jay case that got leased out
but George was so awesome and Bryce and
so they decided to temporarily hopefully
I scare me very loud alright we just
finished filming me and just headed out
here's Mickey here's des here's Bryce oh
wait is it on brand to tell your view
it's not on brand so bleep it out we
talked about but yeah I was telling them
that we actually switched out the sets
because there's a party set had to get
leased out so we're here temporarily
mm-hmm
yeah and then I also told them that
we've been working on something pretty
funny is gonna be pretty cool you better
watch it
better stay tuned I'm better excited go
subscribe to all channels and all
instagrams and all the Widders
everyone's everything I'll be having but
yeah it's kind of cool we get to hang
out today's a Saturday so we get to
spend our entire Saturday together and
this is honestly my most favorite day of
the month oh I get to spend with all
these ladies you do but and then Jess
you recently moved out yeah we got our
car towed yeah yeah okay so I didn't
know that the lot just outside of the
gate is like at ozone I thought oh they
don't have to come inside the property
yeah so they won't get towed an 8-cent
but it turns out they want you to go
through security they want you to
register your car get a day pass and all
the sound I like live kind of far from
the security gate so I was like yeah so
much easier face park outside and inside
told them and then does it bozo makes me
hard I got towed because I had a bird
yeah and then yeah
so I'm like well we were making memories
so you better very motley man I told
them to park there so I paid for the
champagne gee yeah I was like if I don't
occasionally I'm oh if I don't pay for
this I'm gonna be guilty for the rest of
my life I'm just gonna smell it belly's
hard out and pay for it because I told
him to give you good tote at my place
okay three why do you arrest at your
place yeah well I know and then so like
we were all together because we're all
meeting and by that point cuz it was so
late that I was like Nick am slipping
over your house like I can't live her it
was like midnight and then so then this
whole like towing situation happened so
then just drives us over to the tow
truck place and they're not gonna have
the car ready until like 1:30 and then
so they were like girl just take a lift
home when we shot hey [ __ ] early this
morning so yeah wake up really early I
know it was a day right have seen great
lion colors you stay tuned on this new
project you know you don't think you
don't know you don't think you know like
you couldn't even know what you like you
gotta check it out you gotta stay tuned
we're all like delirious from those
sleeps right all right guys we just
finished our shoot day we just wrapped I
don't know if you've noticed but I
actually put on lashes and I'm like in
loving and like I'm in love with putting
lashes on now and I think this is gonna
be the new norm when I film but if you
look really closely I didn't really get
them on very well which lashes is it oh
I got him from Sephora oh yeah yeah they
were like 12 bucks just my brand yeah
that's it I want to get something like
really late yeah thank you know I've
only ever worn lashes twice before and
the first time was for my wedding and it
was like more natural and I looked
really good and
and the second time was at this like
event where they glam me up like crazy
and it was like whoa there's an animal
on my lips I got pretty easily had a
pillow yeah it was like too wild
thanks for coming I love it yeah super
cute guys everyone's so hot such a tiny
camera I know it's a small camera follow
your face
if I move yeah yeah did you have fun
today uh yeah it was super fun I always
look coming here cuz I feel like we
always have like except such deep talk
yeah we go cleanse yeah that's true she
pulls off those lashes really oh yeah
you do weird yeah lashes like I felt
like you have the right eyes shape for
it like for me it like took over my eye
and like it looked like I had a unibrow
way and all the way up here that's true
I don't think I was Eugene Levy I don't
like to cut them like in the outer
corners and then they don't look so like
oh you guys like your fragrance Isis
that's true yeah so that might help too
girl you don't even need them your
eyelashes are so long but utilizes our
long - but mine's assorted my sort of
getting bald that's why I had to put
them on but yours are so full I look
really good
hi guys I'm on set with the lady we're
about to film our last pitch episode oh
man ever the last ever last spoilers
spoilers eyelashes eyelashes on love
[ __ ] it's so good it was bomb giving it
like out of a VJ give you a freebie gee
thanks thank you thank you it will
happen your eyes really she went bean
does it but anyway so today we're
actually gonna be transforming this set
and it's gonna be awesome
we cleared it out we're gonna start
painting now we're painting the walls
everyone's working hard okay so the plan
today is
our last episode of hey [ __ ] and then
do the whole set and while we wait for
the paint to dry we're gonna do some
photos and then we're gonna try to
squeeze in two episodes of our new or
like the the new set I guess is what it
is and we're also like rebranding I'm
planning for for this video to come out
once everything's already been announced
oh dang it's raining Oh none of this is
gonna be a surprise to you guys cuz you
would already have heard about all these
changes but I'm documenting them today
for limb memories and also to bring you
guys around to see everything Brice is
taking down our old hey [ __ ] set like
the thingy you actually made this brace
what that's so that is so cool it's so
creative
oops sorry I just realized I was cutting
out your head when you were talking all
right you ready we got to get some work
done you have to dance it first I'm
gonna go change my clothes so we could
get the painting
[Music]
and look at uh everyone's in pages don't
put me in the same firm is Nikki oh I
look bad sorry oh pretty and then jess
is over there curling your hair but we
changed it to PJs and we have the wall
pizza doesn't right now everyone looks
so good
and Nikki picked out all of the PJs yeah
personality yeah Gina personality is my
channel
Gina's personality they can't censor
that oh yeah so we are in the middle of
finishing the sets the new set
intermediate set oh sorry
intermediate say it's a temporary set
but it's the new temporary set and we're
about to put all of this is about to go
on the walls and the floor and the
everything all of this we're about to
make it wonderful aren't we yeah
including including the it's already
right here everything you see laid out
in such a fashion it is aesthetically
crazy
I love that voice oh yeah look at this
he looks so comfy oh my oh that is my
channel it's my channel no this is a
pg-13
[Music]
look at this so we're fully not done we
still have to put this on the wall but
this is what we got so far
Oh Steve is here hi Steve I'm just
pleased to refer to be perfect but
you're only a photographer for Nicky for
oh no wait the group - oh yeah you are
for big men big photo shoot today big I
need you just make mine inside and
really appreciate that I'll get a good
size bed we can appreciate the
opportunity
Hey anywhere you guys can hit me up
podcast at Nicky Lemos where you can
reach me and uh thanks please I'd love
to get the workout where I do weddings
as well perfect
yeah Nicky you did so great you shot all
the but the solos for the girls I love
it was so good and I was really fun -
you made it really fun and relaxing
because I usually hate taking photos and
I get up but it was really fun seeing
the final result am i thinking like okay
so he's like he shoots models all the
time
but then also like it's a man so I can
see also thinking like what else is he
thinking while he's doing his job have
you got anxiety is insane anxiety I
wasn't thinking any of that yeah he
needs to either be gay or a woman for me
to do better photo shoot
oh look at how cute this is so adorable
well look at that is so cute it's all
security round one you married that
[Music]
all right check it out we be niched you
got some tiny little fairy lights you
got a lava lamp we got some neon lights
and then all these photos we're done now
we gotta film some episodes and then
call it a day but good job
[Music]